what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today
so we are about to show you guys our
reaction for brooklyn nine-nine gotta
give a little bit of a disclaimer here
this reaction no matter how many times i
edited it kept getting blocked worldwide
so in order to get it unblocked i had to
be a little bit more sparing with the
footage and audio
included and i know other channels had
issues with this particular episode as
well
but you know what i still think this
reaction turned out pretty good
i think you guys are gonna enjoy it but
no matter how much detective work i did
of my
own to get it unblocked the video itself
still got a copyright claim
so speaking of detectives did you know
that chris
rock played a detective in a movie a
couple weeks ago that came out in the
theaters and is now out on video on
demand
what we got a sponsor today that's right
guys
spiral if you haven't heard it's the new
film in the saw series and if you're a
soft fan
you're going to want to check out this
new direction it's available now on
video on demand so hey
grab yourself some popcorn and your very
best friends imagine what these cops
might be like in a saw scenario but
either way check out spirals yes john
and i saw this movie together and it was
a really fun movie to watch with a
couple of buddies it weirdly felt like a
fun hangout movie
yeah you know you got a little bit of
that 48 hours by yeah you know they
links detectives in spiral
detectives brooklyn 99 this sponsor
totally blends thank you so much spiral
on video on demand
sorry sarge halloween is the worst
plus all the girls think they have to
dress sexy i know that is the worst
please make them stop who wants to have
sex with a tree
was it a maple was it a maple
pretty cool storm huh stem short for
costume
i i've used it dumpy chuck norris
no don't be ron weasley no obviously
miranda from sex in the city
guys i'm mario batali malto mario
celebrity chef
a sweet battalion costume dude thank you
there is a man with impeccable taste
[Laughter]
and the food network eric stultz from
mask
i'll take it
we need two undercovers at the dekalb
street warehouse party uh
boyle you're already in costume as uh
joy behar
oh mario batali okay
magically make everyone kind sober and
fully dressed kind sober and fully
dressed good news everyone we found the
name of santiago's sex tape
just arrested my first halloween idiot
of the season
he was trying to rob a bank but had a
little trouble with the getaway
trying to split huh
[Laughter]
don't touch the money herps are so
stupid i'd make a better criminal than
any of them
yeah you would you'd be an evil
mastermind and everyone would call you
the handsome bandit
and the best part is none of you could
catch me oh
come on i'm fairly certain you wouldn't
be caught no scratch that
i'm 100 sure you'd be called oh here we
go
all right challenge accept what's the
most valuable thing in your office my
medal of valor god you are such a hero
midnight tonight i can steal the medal
of valor from your office
why would i possibly agree to that
because if i lose i'll work the next
five weekends
no overtime but if i win
you won't you have to do all of my
paperwork tonight the busiest
and spookiest night you have to publicly
state
that i'm an amazing detective slash
genius
and this won't interfere with you doing
your job you mean my job as an amazing
detective
genius no it will not i'll do all of my
work guaranteed i'm considering it
i'm interested i agree to participate
this timing is magical
some guy dressed as a rope baby punched
him and took his wallet
she keeps laughing at me tina
we never talk anymore what's the
captain's schedule like today i'm not
gonna help you rob him
his assistant and i take that job
incredibly seriously you're literally
making paper airplanes out of police
reports right now
well how am i supposed to get it into
that garbage can come on
nice good shot downstairs in 10 minutes
the best
what does your skin taste like dina
lohan i'm wearing her face ah
that's it that's it is this costume so
stiff and what is that smell the
department never washes them so it's
probably vomit
oh my come on ma'am no open containers
um why should i listen to you bone
person
it's called a skeleton
you guys are cops these guys are cops
santiago
oh no are you in my ceiling peralta
no you wait for me to leave my office
lower yourself down take my medal and
win the bet
who are you talking to there's no one up
here oh no
right now i'm taking my medal off the
wall and placing it in a locked safe
whose combination is known only to me
the same intern
i'm off to my meeting good luck with the
plan you think that scares me
i laugh in the face of adversity are you
still there
captain are you still there i can't oh
yeah how's the unwinnable bet going well
on the one hand i fell through the
ceiling and onto a pencil
you know frankly i'm a little surprised
you don't think i can win this thing
you're always telling me how i'm the
best
you're the best jake paperwork delivery
you're the best jake oh god hey you're
the best
thank you charles yeah maybe it's just
charles
you need to be more like boyle you're
the best greg thank you
it's about captain hope man's a genius
he's had your number at every turn
well not this day turn
time
aragorn oh strong
damn he really did just pick him up yeah
number three
step forward and say give me your money
you stupid bag of crap
give me your money you stupid bag of
crap no wrong giant baby
are you doing drugs worse selling drugs
worse how bad could it have been making
drugs
number three step forward and say the
word worse
worse nice costume peralta
no peralta here just a normal janitor
pushing trash around
come out of there
captain hey this whole janitor gambit
was designed to fail
it's just like in chess sometimes in
order to win you have to sacrifice your
king
that's exactly how you lose it
this is a game of concentration jake so
focus your mind
start shooting
[Music]
now you're a master of chess huh uh i'm
not a dumb butt
i had a diversion planned there was just
a slight timing issue
oh no there's a big fire
captain you better head over there for
like 15 minutes and see what's going on
with that
beware of the backdraft i'll be in your
office you have beautiful eyes
come on amy loosen up you look like such
a cop it help you blend in
stop trying to get me to love halloween
it'll never work
he ditched the drugs i'm on it oh
no oh god
oh okay ah
yeah man oh
oh no i'm gonna have to call you back
wait stop scratching me we're supposed
to be a team
i was just photocopying some stuff are
you trying to jam pigeons into my air
conditioning fan to flush me out of my
office
way to ruin the surprise how did you get
those birds
oh god so far you and your big fat brain
are losing maybe if we're talking about
who's winning our bet
but if we're talking about who's holding
more birds i'm winning
four nothing you're only holding two
yes oh no
animal killer guy walked by in full
astronaut costume
gave me a high five he high-fived me too
darn it i wasn't supposed to talk but i
got so excited about that astronaut
what is happening amy paid me 50 bucks
to trade places with it for the rest of
the night
really yeah i'm going to use that money
to buy two suits
i'm just sick of losing the halt i want
that medal it's not real gold i tried
selling it online
zero bids we would have won if natasha's
water hadn't broken oh natasha had her
baby you know natasha
yeah yeah her dog has lupus
all right i'm gonna go cry i
kind of feel bad for him don't he
brought this on himself
you paid money to get out of working
with me charles i had to tonight has
been
awful you keep the wig i don't need it
anymore
oh i don't really need it either
hey captain holt can you come out here
for one sec
floorgasm you need something yes i do
hit it royal babies
my god what no give me my keys will you
stop catching me do you have any idea
how much i spent on key chains
23 wow that is unbelievably close 22.76
what do you say we call off the bet
pretend this whole thing never happened
oh i'm not letting you off the hook
what no i meant to give you an out
so you can save face this is getting sad
yeah for you i called your school
and i managed to get a hold of one
sister bernadette
i remember that old bag she was my
favorite
the reason i left catholic school was
because i got into the american ballet
academy
i was a classical dancer i knew you were
a big fan
i break your face no you won't
you're too sensitive oh no oh terry
some officers just arrested peralta what
they caught him scaling the side of the
building with a blowtorch
[Music]
oh no captain welcome to the end game
man who defeated you oh
oh that hurt
[Laughter]
seemed like a natural reaction you
remember when i fell through your
ceiling i admit a disastrous failure but
it gave me the idea for herman the
friendly janitor you met
come out of there as it turned ocean's
11th soccer
of course i had to find a way to get her
out of your office without you seeing
her
so i created a diversion
so she could escape unseen what about
the pigeons their only purpose was to
draw you into the copy room while two
members of my team broke into your
locked office
[Laughter]
you needed a way into the scene you were
so concerned with getting your keys back
you didn't even notice the sergeant
steal your phone
that's right inside i then had charles
dust your screen cover for prints the
greasiest smudges revealed the four
numbers you use the most
the four numbers in your passcode use
the same passcode for everything
your phone your email and of course
you're safe
and how was flirting part of the plane
oh it wasn't it just ruled
when amy came to your office and told
you that i'd been arrested
and as you walked over here charles
awkwardly stuffed himself through your
window and opened your safe
we had the four numbers of your code
which meant there were 24 possible
combinations for charles to try that
could take up to four minutes which is
why i
really dragged out this explanation
means boyle is either on the other side
of that door holding your medal
or i've lost well captain it's
oh you understand
20 seconds to spare
[Laughter]
yes how did you get everyone to help you
i appealed to their sense of teamwork
and camaraderie with a rousing speech
that would put shakespeare to shame
for too long
my speech did not inspire them come on
so i bribed them i told them that if we
pulled this off i would do all of their
paperwork
and since you're doing all my paperwork
i'm impressed peralta
[Laughter]
well this halloween i was the jerk i'm
sorry about tonight
i'm sorry about tonight we found the
title for santiago's follow-up sex tape
halloween is unbearable but
it was slightly less unbearable with you
don't okay
yeah only one there
not wearing a stum oh my god
stooms no i believe you have an
announcement to make so the floor is
yours
attention everyone jake peralta
is an amazing detective genius
now if you'll excuse me i have some
paperwork to do
all right no way he had 19 wallets in
his diaper
we got a runner
i didn't tell you i got kicked out of
ballet school
beating the crap out of ballerinas good
thing we gave them a heads up
team effort go nine-nine
oh boy that was incredible
that was absolutely incredible new
tradition is born
that was that was awesome i'm so glad
peralta won
that made me so happy they had me
guessing
i didn't know which way it would go yeah
you right up until the very end i was
like oh i love all this like elaborate
planning and seeing how they're all
working together
that's really cool when you you see the
unity between all them even santiago
getting involved
but right up until that very moment till
the door open i'm like it can go
either way right now and i
don't know which one i don't have a
prediction it's so fun
it's so fun because usually by like in
any show by that point you're like okay
he won
um but i love how they had you get they
had you on the hook
until that very last moment when they
opened the door
brilliant yeah so freaking funny that
was hilarious
and i like the b story too with rosa and
terry
oh yeah fun stuff well yeah and it takes
perfect advantage of andy samberg's
boyish like always caught off guard
explanations for situations so like when
he's
explaining the diversion as being
intentional like it works perfectly
as something you wouldn't believe but
then you can also sit there and go i bet
he's using that to his advantage and
yeah like
i love when a comedy like this
especially like a 20-minute sitcom or so
can actually ring
a legitimate bit of mystery out of
something because you don't have to do
that and i feel like yeah in a lot of
other shows it would be kind of
evident which way it's going to go after
a certain point so
kudos to them for actually and
especially in a show about detectives it
makes
me that much more appreciative of that
effort yeah
it's a there's a really great set up to
it all in it and yeah because
because holt every episode has
demonstrated that he knows peralta
better than peralta knows himself
so it seemed very likely that peralta
would ultimately lose in the end and
suffer the consequences for it
but what i always appreciate about what
we've seen so far is that
while peralta on the outside comes
across like a doofus
child almost idiot really he is
really good at his job and he is really
smart and clever so i love that i got to
be on display and have the switch of
dynamics where even
uh holt seemed an admiration of peralta
which was great this is great stuff
i would have liked a little bit more of
like a better understanding of the
the actual case they were trying to
solve with uh
boyle and santiago yeah with the drugs
yeah i didn't really feel like i
amounted
to much of anything but that wasn't
really the point the point was the
halloween spirit and honoring that and
then feeling neglected for it which i'm
sure you can identify with john
because you are a very big halloween
enthusiast
that's right and so then in more ways
than one you are
like boyle i would just like yeah i mean
it would be boyle in this situation
probably would be more
than a lot of situations probably
santiago and a couple of other ones so
they're the perfect characters to pair
up for me
and yeah i mean like the andy sandberg
and whole plot line the the peralta and
whole plot is
the centerpiece and the main thing it's
weird because
it's not even a gripe but i guess i
would have selfishly liked to have yes
spent more time
out and about with charles and amy just
because you know that
is a bit more i feel like brief as
compared to the other parts of the story
and it's the most halloween involved
yeah yeah so you know in an episode
about halloween it would have been cool
to yeah go out
into new york especially because i've
never experienced it in new york so i'm
sure you know that's something i've got
to look forward to for future halloween
episodes or whatever but
as a first one and as an introductory
like it still feels like halloween and
it's still fun to have like all these
different
wacky costume people in the precinct and
doing the lineup they're doing the
tricks part of the trick-or-treating
yeah yeah that's what they're really
honing in on
and yeah learning a little bit about
rosa's soft spot
i heard this that's a voice that she
really puts on yes i have no idea what
she actually sounds like i i don't
i've heard that at such a point in the
show when she like
mocks other female characters or
something like that her true voice will
come out
so if she does a voice from my
understanding it'll be the real thing
i like when they mix up the bonding
dynamics because everyone seems so
intimidated by rosa and
it feels like her toughness threatens
her but terry
is not really affected by that uh
that persona that she puts on especially
because he's terry look how buffy is
he's a sensitive character so he would
admire more of the sensations of her
which i really like
yeah they're kind of like funny inverses
of each other because
he is so cuddly yet so huge and she
is yeah so intimidating and yet you
wouldn't necessarily expect that
it seems like they have fun with the
writing of who to pair people off with
like this one was the first time you got
just santiago and boyle
and then another b story was with
terry and rosa and so it's cool that you
can get different
layers of comedy from these actors and
the writing just from
the attention to detail they have of
each one of their characters the
understanding of them all
so yeah that was really solid and the
other thing that i really took notice of
in this episode is this show has some
damn
great editors the editing on this is
strong like i really know i really
noticed it in the scene
when the dancers were there as a
distraction they're swapping the keys
because for a show like this that is
as handheld as it is as much as there's
like punching in and punching out that
they're doing
it's really easy in almost anything
think of like a paul greengrass movie or
something where
a sequence like that could have easily
been very difficult to keep up with what
they're doing and it could distract from
the actual comedy
at hand but the timing of their cuts and
choosing which angles to roll with
because you're constantly dealing with
these
camera angles that are kind of going in
and out the whole time and are handheld
i think the editing that they do is
really strong and there's also
more cutaways more than the other
episodes we've seen so far so you also
got to make that flow
and yeah this was the first time i
really took notice of how
great the editing is in this show yeah
cause when the dancers come in like it
does
they manage to put you right there and
then it sweeps you off guard and then
the surprise
really hits and yeah i mean they know
well enough when to use
wide angles here and there because you
know it is kind of
mildly impressive that they put together
this little routine with all the keys
being thrown around like it has a real
sense of imagination and it's probably
more
uh you know thought out than you might
expect i would imagine that's
what i keep the sense i keep getting
from the construction yeah
of the episodes good the review is now
complete
the thoughts and opinions have now been
formed and will be inserted into the
video
where the few will remain to hear the
opinions and analysis
of a 22-minute comedy episode one that
is meant for just laughs and what
probably would have sufficed is that's
just saying
that funny [ __ ] funny episode
i know we do it for ourselves we do it
for us
for pride just so we can say we're more
than reactors
we we break things down not true at all
guys if you want to see more brooklyn 99
reactions subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell
check out blind wave i think they're all
like on season five or something i don't
know what season they're wrong
and then patients um yeah go check them
out
and hey we are we we do know some people
have been asking for twice a week
a lot of people have been asking for
twice a week it's the most popular
comment every other day i won't go into
all the
ins and outs and details but we're
always down to the wire
to get these up on just sunday
so bear with us as we so there's there's
constantly things behind the scenes
where
there's some setback that will happen
um constantly and uh yeah but it's not
our job to put that here on camera for
you guys
it's supposed to look like everything's
just fun all the time
we live in this vacuum of enjoyability
[Laughter]
it's always never ever hard to
i'm tainted by the outside world or the
ups and downs
who have other personal life things that
are like all right i'll take on more to
do then so that way you can have some
time away
all right guys well subscribe click the
notification bell
either way the show is always such a
delight and you know
it would be nice to get to twice a week
and maybe one day we will
maybe if you just keep commenting that
eventually will succumb to the pressure
and then eventually people would be like
too much yeah go back to
maybe have not given me time to miss
your reactions to brooklyn
yeah yeah i need i really need to build
up that fondness
yeah yeah kind of used to it now so i'm
not going to watch it as much
don't don't wear yourself out guys pace
yourself don't binge too hard
all right hey let's do a
jn valente i don't know why i'm wearing
my headphones jay and valente
i wanted to shout you out in this one
specifically buddy
because here's the honest to god truth
we currently have 30 people we got a
shout out this month
and if anyone could be a hard-boiled
film noir detective
with insane inner monologues
it's easily you anyone who's read
one message from you whether that be
text or email or a patreon message
on a screen yes it's very obvious
you would have the most awesome
existential contemplative type of
internal monologue to be a detective and
you probably would solve the case you
might spend a little too much time
down at the bar drowning away your
sorrows
but you still solve the case in the end
maybe even take a bullet
yeah yeah you solve the case like while
you're drunk and disorderly but that's
the sign of a good detective is like no
matter how terrible your inner life is
you're married to the job and some
people might be like you can't trust him
that guy's
washed up he's a drunk yeah why is he
still even
working shouldn't he be fired tired
he's constantly drinking his challenge
and his weapon on my desk
but you'd still solve it because no
matter how much people doubt you
you're still a damn fine cop and don't
ever forget it
your credit to the force jan valente
officer valente detective valente p.i
dude he got fired on his own now
and he needs the work